I think you should be able to give his
opinion even though a lot of you might
disagree
one I think much is outrageous and
completely just a very radical thing to
say corporate coaching with the Alliance
and the strong background that we have
with the UK to be in one person over
something he said this isn't really a
good idea I think one of the things is
that people are jumping to conclusions
that he's racist by saying if you put a
temporary ban on all Muslims immigrants
and refugees that were coming into the
country back in 2011 and you can
actually look up sources about this
online very easily the Obama
administration actually put a temporary
ban on any sort of immigration from
Middle Eastern countries of Muslims for
the exact same reasons out of fear of
terrorist attacks
the President of the United States that
I mean corn relations how would that
work out and how would we keep our like
relationship with Britain
good relationship and it's just free
speech so you can say whatever he wants